welcome to CBS this morning we're
talking about one of the great symbols
of Paris and all of Western civilization
it is still standing this morning after
a fire that nearly destroyed it
flames brought down the spire and much
of the roof at Notre Dame Cathedral
yesterday and think about this it's the
start of Holy Week this morning the fire
is out in prayers and offers of help are
coming in from all around the world the
cathedrals main altar is covered in
debris right now but much of the
historic interior appears to be okay and
that's great news the fire started
during a major renovation project Seth
Doane is outside Notre Dame right now in
the heart of Paris a familiar sight to
millions of Americans Seth this is tough
good morning good morning the Paris
prosecutor is saying that they are
working under the belief that this fire
was started by an accident and there are
around 50 people working on the
investigation Paris today is stunned is
heartbroken and newspaper writers have
been trying to put those emotions into
words this headline reads tears this one
reads disaster as vicious flames
engulfed the 850 year-old masterpiece of
Gothic architecture France's president
said a part of us is burning and it's
all because it's the symbol if the
symbol of France is the symbol of
generations the fire broke out in the
Attic around 650 local time about five
minutes after notre dam closed for the
day it spread to the roof at the rear of
the Cathedral in less than an hour
flames spread to its giant spire which
just 13 minutes later collapsed
[Music]
400 firefighters battled but at times
appeared dwarfed by the fire which tore
through the soaring structure fueled by
the wood of 1300 oak trees that made a
part of an interior network of wooden
beams dropping heavy water from the air
was not an option for fear it had caused
the entire structure to collapse 2/3 of
the roof was ravaged but medieval
stonemasons may have saved no TRADOC by
doing such a good job on the buttresses
that survived the fire there was a rush
to save artwork and artifacts Paris's
mayor said the holy crown of thorns and
other precious pieces had been
successfully recovered today we're
getting our first look inside where the
cross on the altar appears to shine amid
the devastation stone Saints look toward
firefighters and some pews survived
attention is now turned to the
stained-glass windows and the organ one
of the oldest in the world Notre Dame
had become one of the most popular
sights in Paris attracting about 30,000
visitors a day around 13 million a year
during the fire onlookers crowded onto
bridges and streets watching in horror
powerless some frayed were broke into
song
the French president was defiant nubira
lady the worst has been avoided he said
the Cappadonna adding we will rebuild
other presidents a Pope and people
around the world have been paying
tribute and also making pledges to help
rebuild no Dom already in the hundreds
of millions of dollars Yale
Seth Doane outside note you down we
thank you
you